okay let's go back to the phone 6 1 7 8
& 3 0 47 50 is the number we'll go to
our next caller from the 503 area code
caller what's on your mind
hi David I'm from Portland and I have a
question about the Russian the no
Russian trolls that come on your show
and they leave voicemails ok but they
know that the people that call in and
still say despite indictments that
there's no Russia story yes please tell
us we're not on speakerphone right right
Mitchell um sorry I only thank you all
yeah thank you I don't know the
etiquette when you call into shows you
know they can go like that yeah all
right okay go ahead I had a question uh
behind why you called them troll still
when a second of talk he managed to form
the progressive voice and the diamond or
storm still say that there doesn't seem
to be any evidence between Russia and
Trump I don't know that they say that I
mean listen I don't really watch any
shows and I don't even know some of the
people you're talking about but is there
a different way you can ask the question
that I might be able to better answer it
because I don't I don't know all those
shows and I don't really watch any shows
it's just calling them trolls and then
when there's a lot of prominent
progressive voices out there that are
also independent media just like yours
it's it's a little strange
the only other independent media source
is very progressive that I found that
agrees that there could be a complete
concluded collusion is the rational
national and even there
listen it's so it's so difficult to talk
about what other people think whose
shows I've not seen for a while and some
of them I'm not even familiar with I
mean do you think that
there was Trump Russia collusion do you
think it's possible that there was do
you think it's been proven that there is
no collusion I don't think it's
improving that either way but from the
evidence of the announces so far I don't
believe it is it is the case that there
has been collision okay so like jr. met
with the Russian lawyer and she promised
dirt on Hillary and Trump jr. said we
might be able to look at you know I want
I want more information about this and
if we win we might be able to look at
changing the Magnitsky law which is like
a pretty quick pretty pretty clear
intimation into a quid pro quo you
helped us defeat Hillary we might change
the Magnitsky law would that qualify
because remember collusion is not a
legal term collusion is canon is an
umbrella term that it can could include
a lot of different crimes would that be
an example maybe I would have to know
more about that but if it's as I
describe it would that be an example if
there's no definition then potentially
yeah okay so what you're saying is that
there's actually a very specific way at
least one that I've named just in the
last 30 seconds that would qualify as
Trump Russia collusion whatever come
from I'm sorry
not something that was not Trump and
stuff that was from fun ah is is your
statement is your assertion that unless
Donald Trump personally was the one
doing the collusion that there was no
Trump Russia collusion is that the idea
that when we say Trump we have to mean
Donald Trump personally I'm just trying
to figure out what your expectations are
no I'm saying that I'm saying that I
don't believe there's evidence and
enough evidence to say that has been in
terms cross a collision and quite
frankly it doesn't seem like we're
getting closer to it in what way are I'm
getting closer but we used to have no
investigation then we got an
investigation then we got three
indictments one of those indictments
become a guilty plea
Michael Flynn is about to be indicted we
just learned that Donald Trump jr.
appeared to have offered a quid pro quo
to change a law that Russia wants
changed in exchange for damaging
information about Hillary Clinton so how
are we aren't we getting are those steps
away from collusion or towards collusion
well what about Syria and about Syria
from Syria has nothing to do with this
are the steps out material are they
messaging or are they moving us away
from collusion I mean we thought of
major things since on Russia I mean even
if we do small things that improve our
relationship with foreign nations it
doesn't show a direct collusion between
Trump and Russia but you're not
answering my question what I'm asking is
from where we started nine months ago to
where we are now have we moved in the
direction of getting away from a
possible collusion or have we move
towards possible collusion we've not
really gone anywhere just because
there's an investigation going on just
because we've been met with but you
would say this so then you would say I
matter what right no matter what even if
we had a dozen indictments let me put it
a different way okay here's where I
think we're gonna get where the rubber
meets the road what would you need to
see to believe that there was collusion
like actual like actual evidence of
Trump Russia collusion and what would be
an example of that like direct documents
that show that Trump was colluding with
Russia knowingly Trump personally or
people that were running Trump's
campaign people possibly directed by
Trump what do you what do you mean
I see your point David um I did not call
into the show prepared to answer that
question well let me put it a different
way is there anything that would
convince you that Trump colluded with
Russia because I've given you the plenty
of opportunities to tell me exactly why
you don't think what we've seen points
in that direction I've given you an open
forum to tell me what if I could present
it to you would change your mind and
you're unable to tell me so is it
possible that you've decided already
that there was no collusion and you're
not really open to having your mind
changed no I I see a very similar
perspective only on the opposite end of
what you're coming up
no no it's abundantly clear that you
have a different perspective my question
is it doesn't sound like you're actually
open to having your mind changed because
I've asked you what would change your
mind and you haven't been able to tell
me like actual evidence between like the
actual concrete evidence not just but
what would that be like you need a video
of Trump and Putin doing something I
mean like what what would be that
evidence there just hasn't been any
evidence that would suggest it so far
and unless you know what evidence would
suggest it how can you evaluate the
evidence in other words you must be
thinking of the evidence we have
compared to some standard in your mind
as to what would count as evidence of
collusion so what would count as
evidence of collusion yeah I would know
it when I see it
ah you would know it wouldn't see it
alright well that is the exact line I
was waiting for okay thanks for the call
listen I think that whether or not I'm
calling people trolls I think that this
sort of ideological commitment to a
conclusion before we even really
evaluate how we've gotten there is is
sort of the problem so I appreciate the
call Mitchell thank you very much yeah
David I really appreciate it as well I'm
a huge finish so I hope I don't get
there as a troll no no but I see the
same thing on your side I feel like a
lot of the indictment is just tax
evasion and
is being connected as a term pressure
thing okay well we will ultimately see
I'm ready I mean I could tell you like
here's what would convince me that there
was collusion here's what would convince
me that there wasn't but I think it's
important to sort of know that all right
Mitchell thank you very much very much
appreciate it